hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three games this o is not
an official game okay I wasn't gonna
assume that it was a fifty an official
game even though apparently in a
spongebob episode recently which is
still being made which is news to me
they acknowledged creepypasta Squidward
which is very bizarre
very bizarre very weird very weird
penguin
there's the crusty seller oh I like that
starting right for the menu that's good
touch go down and talk with mr. Krabs
about what what do what do i need to i
thought this is gonna be a wild hunt for
you the creepy abandoned horrible
horrible listen spongebob me boy
bad news I hit the formula in a
chocolate bar I don't like his voice
lost down here find it for me okay thank
you alright can do anyway you're weird I
don't think I like you very much
also I don't like this amnesia ass duck
here Oh God hey you sure about this
don't worry it's fine
find the chocolate bar you know I could
just go buy you one you got a lot of
money [ __ ] that's creepy you got a lot
of money here you could just buy one hey
balls okay alright boss you got it boss
sorry
am I supposed to do something about that
or is it about all this what do what hi
hello okay hey chocolate hey that's good
return to mr. crook okay good yeah I
yeah totally
hi hello okay oh oh you do it I don't
understand are you like it are you gonna
kill me or you're not really oh oh wait
whoa oh God oh okay
well then I will admit that his dad is a
little weird oh oh okay I didn't make
any goddamn sense okay no spongebob me
boy bad news
I hid the formula in the chocolate bar
oh that's what if that's what it is
the formulism
I need my reading skill or I can just
give plausible deniability hey Lexi and
make sure you go back and you scrub the
fact that the formula was it just cut
that little portion out so that nobody
will be the wiser right okay cool good
Hey excuse me I need to get by you thank
you goodbye see you around
oh hi you're weird I don't like you I
don't like you at all
okay okay okay okay okay okay find the
chocolate bar yeah I'm on it I'm on it
but I know yeah that's it's very
concerning of you screaming on the other
side of this but you leave okay you left
I don't know how far you left to but I'm
gonna go I'm gonna try to go I guess I
could go this way but this is gonna be
right there yeah he's right there okay
welcome there hey lady
yeah thank you lady thank you lady um
yeah I mean other than being moderately
disturbing I you know it's not that bad
who's screaming I'm screaming you got a
mr. Krabs you got it I just gotta go get
the jockey bar you wanted to delicious
Chuck but I'll make sure you get
wouldn't be screw Chris excuse me man
you've got like blood on your face I
don't know why you've got blood many
would booze me to actually open these
doors before the before I have to go
through it
wait what where's the choco bar where's
that sweet delicious chalky bar oh hey
there you're okay returned mr. Krabs you
got it whoa hey hi how are you doing
there buddy hey pal okay I can't go that
way that's good no lady please move
thank you okay I don't know if I got
that guy locked down over there or what
but it seems like I might got this in
the bag
Hey looks like I got it in one Oh God
[ __ ] I didn't know if I was supposed
to run down that way or what I guess I
should have just kept moving huh good
what is wrong with your basement man mr.
Krabs what is wrong with your goddamn
money cellar you kinda an issue you've
got lots of issues man lots problems in
here like a lot like a lot of problems
quite a few problems okay I'm just gonna
run for it
cuz I don't know where else to go
excuse me thank you I'm just gonna gun
it okay okay this is fine mr. Krabs
hey shiver me timbers thank you so much
Boyle you employee of the month
[Music]
okay are we gonna talk about that mr.
Krabs because you got like a nightmare
situation going on okay this is not a
game by the owners who no one is gonna
mistake that god you are not going to be
sued hawk sandwich
Dino Hawk sandwich we met you're fine
you're okay hawk sandwich you're fine
it's okay
it falls under parody and you're not
making money although it's father good
all right that was so that was something
yeah that was something all right that
was sure was something
okay good great good stuff all right
welcome to the myth
there was no menu there was no nothing
the game just opened up hello
hello what the hell no instructions no
starting information oh well hello ye
they are everywhere I have grown old
hearing some of them try to escape from
here and saw what happened it's better
to remain being nothing to meet the same
fate they're not from this world
one by one they will get rid of everyone
who is not fit to serve them anymore
they told me I was next
okay cool great I'm gonna pretend like I
didn't hear that just gonna make oh just
good soon there's nothing around this
corner okay good it's me snippy stepping
on the chains that's all it is yes
definitely all it is okay eeny meeny
miny moe I'm gonna go the way with not
the chains ah
dead end good I love dead ends my time
is almost come I cannot take this
anymore I have prayed since forever to
get out of this
no man can stop these monsters these
mosters sorry the most errs the most
errs are unstoppable alright so I gotta
be on the lookout for the most errs the
hosters with the most errs there
definitely would you think that I would
try to be a little bit more stealthy
vote well I'm sorry oh that's just a
chain this is a shadow on the table I
thought those it looked like a portion
or hi is there a note here before taking
his final breath he gave me the
manuscript he kept away from us for so
long it said the end of the years the
time when she comes back to earth she
would clear all the evil from this earth
and restore balance in this world she is
our only hope now is this even real well
frankly I don't know I just woke up in a
dungeon and I don't know why I'm here
what's going on
I'm just gonna keep on mosey
wait a minute I think maybe not oh good
an eyeball my favorite
how are you know I disagree with your
assessment you stuff - stop that right
now this doesn't feel like real but I'm
running out of ideas this is the only
hope we all have now I never believes in
anything he wrote ever but he said that
her idol is hidden somewhere in the
south at the dungeon by these monsters
I'm risking my life trying to find it
back hope it's worth it it's probably
not to be perfectly honest it's probably
very much not hi oh you you sassy sue
stop being so squiggly wiggly okay other
than that that hasn't really been
anything of tangible spookiness as
all right so it's been a little bit of
tangible Smulian is happening hi how are
you can I get around this probably oh
here we go nope nope okay so I can't get
around that so what exactly am I
supposed to do I can't can't jump high
yeah maybe that would be a bit smarter
hey buddy i'ma go this way now i'ma go
this way it worked I never believed that
the idol ever existed maybe or
everything else you've roads correct -
maybe we can get out of this hell all
right sure whatever you say I don't know
about these eyeballs looking at me but
Dez that's a different story
no no no they got to know about our
plans I heard that they were searching
for the hideout the idol is not ready
yet we're gonna fail after all these oh
two eyes okay now it's getting spooky
that's getting a little spooky I've
never bet anything with one eye that was
scary
this is I knew it all right got a
Pokemon whoa is that Pokemon is that
Bulbasaur
that's not Bulbasaur that's tough enough
hi hello how hi how are you I'm falling
now I'm falling I can't move I can't
move
I'm not moving I'm dead
[Laughter]
okay I don't give it you scure piece of
poopy I don't get it what do you mean
what are you I don't understand well
that's the myth I guess we'll never know
it's myth I guess I'll just be on my way
and mosey on to the next game then this
is the other world I don't know what
that lady's doing over there probably
dying but we're gonna find out controls
wise to look around interact flashlights
print other world vision weird oh that's
me hello how we all doing you good you
waking in the dark for in place you have
November oh you were right
okay good I love bright flashes of light
mm-hmm patient report Wednesday that's
pretty clever I like the way the main
menu is incorporated into the first room
and Christopher Noah date of birth 13th
1971 can manipulate objects within the
other world but often cannot exit the
realm at will is often stuck there for
hours and you okay yeah so Christopher
stuck I see Wednesday 10th of January
just about what the doctor has told me
the right strumming patterns used to
induce the other will transition there's
some glaring flaws in their design is
working on a new pattern that should
increase the patient's responsiveness
and control in the other world you
should be ready tomorrow and I look
forward to testing it out opening can
increase the efficiency of some of our
more lacking subjects though the patient
13 is good candidate for the new Straub
remains to be seen what a success it was
what greatness it brought us she could
not be tamed this monster of our own
making
all right good great not like this other
world thing getting double opinions on
everything I read patient report will f
brim show some promise in his ability to
enter the other world that will however
his frail Constitution makes him a poor
candidate for some of the more dangerous
aspects of Rome shifting often comes
back bruised and scared frail well hey
how you doing here
patient report Michael Downey scrap of
what my previous report said after
Michael had an encounter with Basin
thirteen you no longer seems to connect
as well to the other world strobing
brings him there for a moment but he
could no longer enter their zone will be
soon thirteen seems to be jamming the
potential of her peers
he's scared am i am i patient thirteen
also what is that in there hello use
this power at your own caution some
things appear twisted in this realm like
a key I don't know seems I'll find me
everything schemes seems it seems good
Gregory Hutchinson seems to lack
potential has little control over his
ability to remain in the other world
gets irrational and violent little
promise worthless alright good that's
pretty cool I gotta admit this pretty
cool
Laura Connors ID number thirteen so
significant signs of psychic potential
immediate results from strobing can not
only see into the other world buts
control aspects of it should we move to
a more secure location as there are
concerns her powers are influencing the
world around her security systems are
malfunctioning during her worst phases
beware of Laura do not underestimate her
we were fools to think we can control
her her birth holds the key that hinders
our progress yeah you better watch out
for me baby I'm pretty strong pretty
good the world around you is not what it
seems you have the ability to gaze
stuffers beware of the consequences okay
find a way out of the room oh you oh
[ __ ] oh God
so soft burn in hell so tired hello her
birth my doom stop the lights I refuse
[Music]
Christopher 13th of December of 1971
okay her gaze lingers Michael 28th of
September 1970 oak Laura 19th of October
1974 she was special
she's here oh that's funky that's funky
free I don't need a hint them good doors
locked need a keypad okay I can't go
Otherworld here so the birthday to me oh
happy birthday to me happy birthday to
me 19 October 1974 so 1910 1974 so I
wrote that note take the elevator to
freedom okay I don't need to be told
twice on what goes to freedom or not
okay
[Music]
okay I'll go the other way you know I
don't trust that you're not budging
okay well but seems rusted alright good
good good
Oh give me luck maybe maybe not grape
doesn't seem like there's anything here
that I need to get I think I should go
through the door that opened up for me
yeah it seems like it maybe should be
something I need to do okay hi Hey
I wasn't running away be brave okay
there's something about this thing the
engine needs to replace three part use
other world vision to locate three
engine parts in the nearby room oh is it
that easier oh it's not easy okay
easy-peasy all right hey nobody in here
there it is my crock-pot up an engine
part well mission accomplished I guess
you have one of three parts okay if they
have the three other parts of nearby
rooms hello again
Oh easy as this easy peasy lemon squeeze
me good this seems too easy it seems
like things are going really smoothly I
don't see how they could possibly go any
better than they're currently going
oh hey how you doing it's right in here
that's stupid
the machines fixed great good I will I
will take the elevator thank you I will
thank you
okay well done you escape the building
gray
[Music]
okay did I well you know if something
makes me suspect that maybe I did know
[Music]
you're just gonna leave me hanging like
that you're gonna leave me hanging I
guess it was just a prototype of God it
was actually interesting I was super
into that it was well polished it wasn't
perfectly polished but you know they did
the best that they could with all the
prefab stuff that I imagine is in unity
okay that was pretty good I liked that a
lot a lot of potentials so when there's
a real game that comes out and goddamnit
they're better actually be a real game
I'm tired of these prototypes coming out
and then they never turn into a real
game because this is good when the real
gun comes out of a player okay that was
good thumbs up whoo thumbs up for
potential one and a half thumbs up for
potential this was three games I hope
you enjoyed it thank you for watching
death we'll see you in the next episode
bye bye